[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec tous ceux qui habitent
à paris anne hidalgo on n'a rien contre
elle mon frère mais à mon avis merci
c'est sûr qu'elle avait une famille
qu'était conductrice de bus soit mais
j'adore le connecteur loin serait faire
maintenant maintenant paris mon frère
c'est à dire si t'as pas un bus tutu sur
la tête de ma mère maintenant tu veux te
ra qui achètent un bus ou faire latter
sûr tu vas tu as et marca com à sa fin
il ya détruit par pour vélo mon frère
pour les bons les voitures tasse et pour
les vélos vous faire et à deux vélos
confrères à l'état de guerre ils sont
contents et ont rasé et regarder tier
one c'est pas ça l'est moins c'est que
j'ai écrit alors vous êtes qui déjà
non pour moi j'ai marcquois mais vous à
barr [ __ ] laveur autour du cou je
t'explique c'est un tournant dans ta
relation ça c'est où vous allez vous
marier or là maintenant ça va se
terminer
moi si j'ai un conseil à donner je vais
te dire la tap à la bonne porte en
premier temps ce qu'on appelle le black
out plus de nouvelles et sommes pleins
sms + un appel deuxième temps là elle va
vouloir te voir l'acte i va hélas tu
mets tout à plat tu dis voilà des
nouvelles règles fatou webb a décollé à
l'aller à tout s'arrête jamais passer ça
pour toi d'un petit koné fatoumata que
des fans s'étaient donné envie de ça va
tous être pas t'étonner fatous cadeau
c'est un mec qui tape du poing sur la
table bay ok j'en ai ras le cul de
doigts tu commences à lui permettent il
faut qu'il apprenne à l'envers ah oui à
tout
[Applaudissements]
écoutez c'était ma troisième place
[Rires]
vous êtes voilà si vous voulez on joue
vendredi je serai prêt vendre de gêner
mission affaire banon mais vendre
retourner mais sur sa voiture
cela fera avancer comme ça on a dit
samedi samedi si vous voulez samedi
quand tu veux tu te sois dit 11h28
demande pas des fûts rentre chez toi
surfaces terre battue
non mais quelle version fastueux je peux
même jouer sur cette bâtisse avait connu
sur la toile doit être chaude à la fois
la notion c'est dur c'est dur ferme à
l'art est mal ça rien ne bougeait pas un
terreau vide on vous dit chaque année
que ça va revenir à un moment c'était
revenue mais intervient le problème
c'est qu'on peut plus faire en direct
parce que c'est trop cher on peut plus
le faire dans les villes parce qu'il
n'ya pas de ville faire en france parce
que c'est trop cher donc ils vont aller
tourner en allemagne ou chez paou là
dans un studio mon frère tu vas avoir
des allemands y laissa même pas ton pas
faire mont de marsan contrebassiste
ben-hur jeu des gones en rien les mecs
viennent birkenstock tout ça c'est
n'importe quoi
on a des nouvelles de rihanna vous savez
que rihanna avait cassé avec son mec
règles pour ma personne et bien rihanna
a trouvé un nouveau mec
depuis tout le monde voulait la caser
avec son ex grecque et finalement non
vous allez voir que rihanna est lié avec
un autre ex donc apparemment elle aime
les ex elle aime les actions qu'il faut
que je la pécho d'abord je savais
qu'elle et après peut-être gélard pécho
moi avons besoin d comment très bien
très très en forme ah oui en plein de
patates j'ai une pêche ça se voit je te
jure de frédéric comment ça se fait ça
parce que alors moi je te dis tu vois
par exemple moi je ne sors jamais je
dors tout et je fais du sport je ne fume
pas je ne bois pas je ne voudrais pas
savoir que sa demande il faut commencer
par bien s'hydrater parce que parfois on
pense qu'on a faim erronée voilà un peu
d'autres deux grands verres d'eau
le pech et frau choyés que je vous dis
je ce soir c'est d'ailleurs ce à quoi je
vais garder cette photo match et dire
qu'il en restera qu de l'année
[Musique]